en todo un desafío se ha convertido el
envío de ayudas humanitarias desde sudán
para los desplazados en la región del
tigre
el 2 de diciembre la onu acordó con las
autoridades de etiopía que los bloqueos
a las presiones de asistencia en las
zonas controladas por las fuerzas
gubernamentales serían levantados pero
los obstáculos persisten y han
dificultado las labores es continuo hay
un apagón continuo en las comunicaciones
lo que hace que nuestra comprensión de
la situación sea muy incompleta y que
nuestro trabajo sea muy difícil por lo
tanto espero que las autoridades de
etiopía eliminen el bloqueo de las
comunicaciones de inmediato y en segundo
lugar permitan el acceso pleno y sin
obstáculos a los trabajadores
humanitarios en esta región de etiopía
en la que el conflicto estalló el 4 de
noviembre los combates han exacerbado el
flagelo del desplazamiento las ofensivas
en las que el ejército federal se
enfrenta a las tropas afines al frente
de liberación popular por el dominio de
la región impidieron el acceso de
alimentos y medicamentos desde hace
cuatro semanas fue prohibido el acceso
de los trabajadores de las misiones
sociales con lo que los campamentos
entraron en riesgo de desabastecimiento
se estima que en el tigre habitan
de 5 millones de personas lo que
equivale al 5 por ciento de la población
del país solo en las últimas semanas más
de 45 mil etíopes han huido a sudan